[Music]
okay this week we've got special talent
uh hey now love test and bear spray
bear spray Cooper Oh bear space crazy
what isn't it it's like space yeah you
spray the bear like if it comes and
attacks you and it's supposed to get
them that's pretty cool
it's like pepper spray before the bear
not what's super crazy strength so for
our first story this man named Yaya 31
years or 35 years old another dumb name
yeah Oh is he from another country he's
from Nepal still be dumb yes oh yeah
yeah he claims to be the only person in
the world who can lick his forehead see
this cow town dude yeah we got to say to
every woman's leg ooh I got to get to
know this guy no particularly good for
he's like you know how that's ridiculous
you don't want a big tongue no go to
your butthole all the way up a regular
good tongue do that let me see this
lizard all right so this it is very
close yeah it's actually really
ridiculous that it's only a sliver of
space between Eddie is pretty ridiculous
yeah
look at that scrunched estimate that's
good as that cheater he's a [ __ ]
cheaters [ __ ] home his nose is almost
between his eyes he only has one tooth
ah
also there's no teeth blocking the yeah
what is that have like a half inch here
we go that makes a difference what's on
his neck oh also he could fold it
sounds like a motorcycle
he's like WI needed his mouth he could
really smell he could suck my boogers
out of his nose you know what that bull
looks like he looks like one of those
Sesame Street characters when they're
very upset I like the music he doesn't
have bottom teeth yes he has no job
eyebrows yeah that's pretty cool
yes no eyebrows sure whatever bet I'm
like no yes appears cool for how long
though the thing that you would see him
one time alright now there's like a
Looney Tunes ostriches in the 1930s he
would have been quite the celebrity at
the Barnum & Bailey [ __ ] circus show
oh the freak show he's got a long haul
the groupies so how'd it happen so he
doesn't have mouth he was that or one -
he has one tooth but neither does Tiger
and he couldn't do that tongue yeah but
I think it is also the fact that his
nose is so short and he does have just a
perfect combination I couldn't get past
my nose I wouldn't be able to oh just no
teeth yeah just the no teeth thing and
so he's able to like go yeah yeah yeah
oh that's like my crappy almost
swallowing he could swallow his face it
seems like he's eating his boogers for
sure
he's [ __ ] eating his boogers for sure
this fool if he was you could maintain
eye contact and liquor boho all the way
down with all the
my god
[Laughter]
you want to lick a butthole you gotta
like your eyes got a disappear one way
if this guy was a girl there'll be a lot
of guys lining up to get licked you want
to get yeah I think that you're thinking
about this guy licking you right no not
me guys are curious but there's a lot of
guys that would do it cuz they're just
don't even [ __ ] animals so I mean it's
we're all like disgusted it's just weird
Joe spitting out facts everyone's like
whatever the other facts those weren't
facts those were like yep fact wait why
is why does he not have teeth I don't
know they didn't explain why but he said
that he discovered he could do this like
licking his own forehead since he was a
kid and so he's now a bus driver and so
he doesn't do that oh so he didn't
parlay that into a great career I know
right kids and stuff who doesn't do it
because we could get it really you don't
scare the [ __ ] yeah I'd be scared as
[ __ ] to as a kid if I saw that [ __ ] yeah
you've on as a kid I'd be scared now you
walk into a bus some guys licking his
forehead turn right around there was a
man who actually fainted from seeing him
he's like that's some devil [ __ ] I'm
gonna wait for the next bus kids would
like it because you know kids always
[ __ ] around with their face oh I hated
that yeah I'll be like uncle yeah I do
that thing with the [ __ ] bow lick
your forehead up I'm gonna put like
peanut butter on his forehead this space
already looks like you do crazy [ __ ]
though yeah just his normal life yeah
this [ __ ] can like [ __ ] and
snap his toes or something
- yeah he looks like a double-jointed
[ __ ] dancer
yeah I guess he looks pretty interesting
yeah yeah I would have no space on earth
dude duffle just looks like he's I know
you don't need to move his ears you know
you could do something where the [ __ ]
are his eyebrows and get this like he
licked them off bleaches goatee or did
it didn't actually turn that color great
question that but that's the moneymaker
man the goatee yeah because you have to
you know oh he's licking it you know
he's gonna tickle it yeah yeah so he's
trying to get into the Guinness World
Records title why is it he in there you
just said he's the only one that can do
that he claims yeah for you a certified
somebody up there's somebody else on
Twitter it's like a meme where a guy
does that [ __ ] - touched her for that I
don't know about touched it but that's
that whole thing with the face sucks in
oh yeah I feel like I've seen this
before - yeah I think my grandma used to
do that to them you have strange you
pick up on it muttering oil on your face
yeah I think a strange [ __ ] going on I
heard that household I think that's why
I'm here alright for our next story
this mom was arrested for faking her
son's disappearance in order to test her
husband's love for his family what a
good wife really my mom would then close
enough Boston out there what it's like
if you have to worry about first of all
if you have to test then you already
know the [ __ ] answer but Asian
culture it's all about testing yeah if
they don't condone talk they don't know
how to resolve conflict they just test
so this is the situation here so there's
33 year-old mother reported her son
missing to clean up how much you love me
by Barbie a house just spread fast on
social media a cute little boy it turned
out that she took her son somewhere
really far away and she had him wait in
the car and was like just wait here
that's even more dangerous than action
so the kid was a sub so she actually
really kidnapped yeah
yeah so she get in trouble so then she
ended up taking him to a nearby village
Wow perfect like you left her kid at a
village and then the father Beijing
women so the dad he works in another
city and so they had like some
relationship problems during that time
associated wanted to test her husband's
love for the family and so instead of
going through therapy exactly
we're talking to her husband Yeah right
I test him immediately he went to go
look for her son so he was just he
passed with a plus she disappeared for
five days also was just like that movies
with what's-his-name good Asian guys
looking for his daughter
searching yes searching real wife search
yet again so they're saying like when he
was talking to reporter he was just so
disheveled he's like I haven't I like
this picture to look at him looking so
hard and then he was like I just haven't
slept in four days I'm looking for my
son
mom just goes okay I believe you you
love us yeah what's the conversation
after don't get [ __ ] out I mean no
wonder they're having marital problems
he's trying to get away from that crazy
ass girl but it doesn't prove that he
loves her it proves that he loved his
son so I was like what was your plan
here lady
yeah anyway she the first test of
another one trying to figure out what
would the conversation have been after
right so he passes the test listen the
cops didn't find out or whatever and
then what was the conversation at the
what do they what did they say it's
probably are you hungry yeah you say
it's a fault it's a there's a charge for
that like a false claim or yes she got
in trouble
exactly she got in trouble she was
arrested on charges of deliberately
creating it's pretty easy and she also
did he bail her out cuz I was show the
real whoa oh yeah
my plan all along is to get caught she's
gonna drag the way she goes do you know
there's levels to this right good job
[Laughter]
obviously really upset especially if
police - cuz they're like we wasted
large amounts of time public resources
yes be a real kid who's missing I know
the [ __ ] village eating bowel but
like in the car this yeah look where are
you mom
I know yes you loving your old kids it's
not even knowing what's happening yeah I
wonder where they went to the bad guys
good that guy's gonna wake up it you
know what he's that kid's gonna grow up
and he's gonna be attracted to crazy
women yeah yeah he's gonna live in a car
he's gonna just like he's gonna want
women to like to do like crazy [ __ ]
nonsense stuff all you might grow up and
be a Chinese down a comedian because you
have health stories now just kidnap your
mom take you to a village to just leave
you there you know like do I know this
is not something that happens on Colin
he goes to America and he talks about
Chinese culture and it's like nobody
what nobody does that [ __ ] what the hell
are you rocket everyone's crying about
that was a cultural thing to prove your
father's laugh yeah your father did
search for you in the village when you
were what kind of water did you eat for
breakfast food dude we have I have okay
I just I see this is the kind of story I
want to follow up on you know what
happened I want to know why they don't
ask the real question yeah I want to
know like where did he go to the
bathroom he was in the village man he
wasn't in the car was away for five days
yeah or five days
was it there like hope it was like
family I hope she didn't just drive to
somewhere village I know okay you learn
to keep my kid for five days I pictured
her leaving him her her kid in the car
and he was living in the car and she
took her over back towards the [ __ ]
City or something
I know no she left them in a billion is
she idiot for auntie or from my death
hopefully yeah so for our last story a
can of bear repellent fell off a shelf
and exploded inside of a Amazon
warehouse that's like the strongest
strongest pepper spray in bear mazes it
comes out like in a [ __ ] cloud and
the only reason why I know this is
because some dude in Sacramento in a bar
[ __ ] bear mace the [ __ ] out of my
friends oh I didn't get sprayed with it
cuz I was further away but you want to
hear some [ __ ] funny you know Vince
yeah so this was we were at a bar and
there was a bachelor party that was
happening there too oh there you go
bachelor bachelorette parties that were
kind of mixed together
long story short one dude was hitting on
this dude was hitting on the the bride
dudes got all gone up like what the [ __ ]
is this guy doing like bring really
obnoxious guy whips out a [ __ ] can of
bear mace praise everybody and then jets
out right what a cowardly move check
this [ __ ] out right years ago I'm
hanging out with Vince and our friend
Rob right and he's talking about this
story about this one time where he bear
maced a crowd in a bowl so that bull it
was okay we found out that was that guy
it was him God so it was a new friend of
mine that [ __ ] bear makes me oh did
you beat him up yesterday Big Bear means
to you well I better make my I didn't
really get it because I was kind of far
away but he bear make seven he just
jetted out so it was here's how we find
out he's a coward
he saw the holy he ran
[Laughter]
just to put it just to put it in
perspective we just had a last week we
talked about a dream where this girl she
I was in a dream with her and then she
got captured by somebody and she
disappeared through a window and in the
dream I just said she's dead and I just
ran so it's very true to life I wasn't
in the vicinity they do so bear mace is
apparently like really powerful [ __ ] oh
yeah like that 2000 pound animal so what
ended up happening here was that 80
workers had burning eyes and throats and
they were had difficulty breathe and
then 24 of them were taken to five
hospitals Wow
and you know it's Amazon warehouse so
there's probably no ventilation or a/c
or anything yeah yeah it's like bare
bones oh come on treating people right
at Amazon aren't they no thank you you
know you'd like deliver a baby and
you're required to be back within 48
hours I don't even have an eternally
good news article where people are
claiming that they were hooping and
peeing like buckets it's one of the
worst places to work they didn't even
give them bathroom break but that's how
you get your pet you know so much you
can order something in the morning get
it at night that's how this is just this
is just like the the meet fail yeah yeah
yeah yeah Grimpen are you still all
ready for Amazon or not well yeah check
it out I can't leave a butcher place but
whoever's working there they can leave
true but you know what that's not
government a sign but people here people
here abuse I here dedication
[ __ ] you know what's hilarious
about what we're talking about like have
you guys ever been on a cruise yes
unfortunate okay I've been on a cruise
to now I've actually worked on a cruise
I've done comedy on a cruise all right
yeah so then the new night you're you
get to go under and eat you're living
underneath this ship sometimes I'm
telling you it's a third world country
underneath there you don't get one of
the cabins like the passengers doing
this not on Carnival you get like you're
like you've just 100 now what I'm saying
it's like you don't realize the reason
why cruises are so cheap is because they
literally have a third-world country
living underneath so it's like really
the Titanic like the bottom yes man and
the people that work there it's like you
know all from foreign countries you know
and they don't even get to go topside
there to request it and that kind of
stuff dude
but yes freaking Amistad underneath
there man it will give the fresh air and
[ __ ] yeah no I'm swear to God
it's a weird that's why everything is so
cheap and everything so like it's you
know because food are they doing cutting
onions down there they are very
affordable what are they doing like they
didn't get the feeling that this guy was
in like that I wasn't like the employee
bar this guy was telling me all about it
man he was just like yeah you know I had
to request to like to be able to go like
during the cruise I get two minutes of
sunlight yeah that's kind of thing man
so what do they do eat the leftovers of
all the taking care of cuz they have so
much food on okay you get like you know
that's the thing about working on a ship
I mean you have like the meals are
provided for and and the alcohol and all
that kind of stuff is very cheap but I'm
just saying this is an example of that
like you know why would you work in an
Amazon warehouse under those conditions
would you do you wanna cruise again or
not
no not list it was like you know I was
like top notch at the time I just wanted
to do it because I was like I don't know
where my career's gonna go so let me
check this out to see if I can end up
here maybe I wondered if I liked it and
it was weird it was just really weird I
want to do it for the fun but work on a
cruise but I see you guys doing a JK
cruise you know you get your fans to go
on a cruise you guys could easily do it
you get up carnival or nor what's a
Caribbean cruise line with a princess
and a Princess cruise and you guys set
up a thing or it's like you know it
happens all the time I wasn't even gonna
do entertainment I'll order surf pizza I
can't cuz like my fear of that is like
there's like 95% of the fans that are
just really cool but there's that 5%
crazy you have to be missed oh this is
the thing I that's what I'm saying doing
comedy on the ship was like Hatley like
you're just know leaving so you walk
around this they god it's the committee
mr. coming do a joke and now imagine if
like if you didn't have a good set oh
yeah then you're just walking around the
ship like a pariah you know people like
this i gar that's not funny over there
you know so it's like it was it was like
tomatoes at you I saw three kinds of
people on the ship
okay old fat and ghetto oh and in any
combination of that
when we went out we really liked a
company like [ __ ] with a girl we
weren't the gentle ones do did you did
you see it because like 80% when we
rolled but when the Sun came out all
these chicks in like [ __ ] thongs and
bikinis were like shaking it like
[ __ ] crazy like what the [ __ ] did
these people come from
they were sleeping all day yeah they
were just sleeping yeah so many fabulous
too though like they the to the
poorhouse on this cruise were they had
somebody administering the bacon because
it cuz at the buffets oh my god you
couldn't just go get cuz they would just
be like you know play by God alright how
much big in come back for more if you
want more and then there's like a small
percentage of like people that are like
sort of upscale so they'll never go to
the buffet they're always eating at the
captain's dinner or that that that you
know that [ __ ] was so cheap which we
found out a way later cuz it's like a
four-course meal for like 18 bucks I
know what they would sell on a ship
Tuesday had like they would sell like
you really great watches on the ship
oh they had like really like they had a
real high-end store and they would give
like a what do you call it that
employees like they're like a discount
big discount cuz I got that all that
stuff was overseas type of stuff so they
have like a lot of good [ __ ] on some of
the ships it's probably Duty is duty
free exactly so it'd be like 40% off
plus duty free I did like I've done I
did like three or four cruises all
together because you would like the way
they would do it too is like you would
fly to like let's say you would fly to
Costa Rica or something you'd fly like
you know some place of the Bahamas then
you would get on the ship and then this
[ __ ] but you know you do shows it would
go back to port and then those all those
people would get off new people would
get on you would stay on the ship go out
to the first location you do shows and
then you get off and fly home from some
remote location that's cool yeah that's
how they did that but it was like you
know and so funny you tell about that
bacon thing cuz I'm like oh [ __ ] how was
that person you would hog the bacon I'll
be like dummy I'm 12 pieces of bacon
like why why do you need 12 pieces if
that's what people were doing is that
that buffet was insane sometimes the
Bacon's tooth and oh the the bread here
we go
the breakfast was good though yeah
breakfast because you can't mess up but
it was the best meal on the cruise the
book that you can mess up lunch and
dinners if he but you can't mess up
breakfast cuz if you mess up eggs who
are you yeah you know kind of idiot
messes up eggs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]